welcome back everyone in Texas the  family of a soldier who vanished from  Fort Hood more than two months ago now  is demanding answers  twenty-year-old private first class  Vanessa Gann was last seen in April the  Army's Criminal Investigation Command is  now looking into her disappearance the  family's attorney is demanding the army  released s'more information you believe  that they are the bases withholding  information from the en family they're  covering up for each other  Seguin was last seen on April 22nd her  car keys wallet and ID were all found in  the armory room on base where she was  working that morning but her phone is  still missing her family believes  someone vanessa knew is responsible and  thinks she may have been sexually  harassed on base the League of United  Latin American citizens has also  launched a campaign now to plead for her  safe return